I want to go over the most common forms
of meditation how each of them work what
benefits each bring and also who each of
them are for next up on our list is
pranayama meditation also known as
breath control meditation how does it
work this form of meditation is more
about controlling the pacing of your
breathing it is actually often taught as
a breathing exercise in the form of the
444 box method basically you breathe in
through your nose for four seconds hold
your breath for four seconds exhale
slowly for four seconds and then wait
for four seconds and then you repeat the
entire process over and over again what
are the benefits to this this form of
meditation is most widely known for its
calming benefits Studies have shown that
it lowers your blood pressure reduces
stress and even helps you fall asleep it
is also one of the only forms of
meditation that have been shown to
strengthen your lungs who is this for
this is a good form of meditation to
practice if you suffer from a lot of
stress or anxiety follow us for more
helpful tips